the second season of you is packed with
Easter eggs including secret Beckham
Benji references 40 discovering the
truth about peach Salinger's murder plus
the iconic carpet from The Shining UPK
we be lovers I'm John and in this video
I'm revealing a teen killer details you
might have missed in season two of you
they will of course be spoilers so take
care if you haven't caught up la life in
its obsession with health and wellness
in particular a satirized in season two
especially by joe who coming from new
york finds Angelenos particularly
irritating interestingly though mundu
switch 40 declared essential to safely
tripping on LSD was actually referenced
in an amusing moment in season 1 when
Joe's colleague Ethan raves about the
moon juice cookbook manager on top bacon
has a dope recipe and moon juice
cookbook cook cosmically for body beauty
and consciousness kill me
sounds great isn't it another season one
cool back pops up after Joe and love
breakup and Ellie sends him a top 10
list of dating apps at number two is
love hooks an app co-created by one of
Joe's previous victims
Benjamin Jay Ashby two failed careers
model homeboy and co-creator of a dating
app that connects people through musical
tastes called love hooks one of the best
hidden links back to Joe's past life in
New York is the name of the store where
he meets love for the first time anavrin
obviously an RN is wait for it
Nirvana spelled backwards Nirvana is
actually the name of the store right
next to Muniz bookstore back in New York
Beck also wore a Nirvana t-shirt in
season 1 and in one of the second season
flashbacks Joe's mother is also wearing
that same t-shirt design so it seems all
this it's likely a hint that Joe is
especially drawn to things he connects
maybe unconsciously to his mother the
original meaning of the word Nirvana is
a state of bliss and tranquility and the
fact that an R Fran is the opposite of
this word might be the first indication
of the Quinns who owned the grocery
store and not quite as lovely as they
might first seem the drug-fueled 8th
episode of season 2 was particularly
crazy and there were also numerous
fascinating Easter eggs which the
showrunners and production designers
snuck into the episode a version of The
Shining hotels carpet with its
characteristic pattern appears in the
corridors of the hotel where 40 takes
Joe and Allie
work on a screenplay which seems
especially fitting as Jack Nicholson's
character also uses a Shining's hotel as
a place to write the scene where you can
spot the carpet plays out in a similar
way to the iconic vision of the twins
that Dany has in the shining in you Joe
is out of his mind on the LSD that
fought he spiked him with and as he
turns the corner of the hotel's corridor
he sees a vision of Candice which
actually turns out to be Dimitri as you
can see the color of the carpet is
different too compared to the one in the
shining but it's the same distinctive
pattern the second shining reference
comes from the hotel room that forty
lakhs Joe into the room number two one
seven is the same number as a haunted
room and Stephen King's original novel
in that haunted room in the shining Jack
Torrance sees a vision of a creepy woman
in a bathtub and during his LSD trip Joe
also sees a ghostly vision of his mother
appeared to him while he's freaking out
in the bathtub and similar to how the
ghosts in the Overlook Hotel in sight
Jack's violent rage so too does a vision
of Joe's mother spur him on to almost
murder 40 it was 40 sudden realization
that Beck was killed by her ex-boyfriend
not dr. Nikki that led Joe to almost
kill Lopes brother but even before this
ultimate revelation 40 was also figuring
out other secret details about Beck
which we can spot by looking closely at
this whiteboard here we can see that 40
is also figured out that peach didn't
commit suicide as the official version
of events stated but that she was
instead murdered Joe is well aware in
season 2 that peaches murder could come
back to bite him one day
given that the Salinger family had a PI
investigating her death at the end of
season one and that he accidentally left
evidence behind that he was at peaches
family home in Greenwich what if it
takes fingerprints what if they take DNA
not like there's a crusty jar of piss
and peaches challengers house or
anything
Joe's paranoia about the Salinger's
tracking him down may well have revealed
itself when he went back to an odd room
for snacks and moon juice during his
crazy LSD filled adventures the next day
when Joe asked Calvin to tell him what
happened when he found him in the store
in the middle of the night Calvin says
okay you got to remember that part where
you were ranting about how the peaches
were Maddy
[Laughter]
coincidence that during his first
encounter with love she jokes to him
excuse me do you think the speech looks
like a but there's a funny bit of
meta-commentary about yous first season
when Ellie passes critical judgment over
40 script for his adaptation of Beck's
book the dark face of love first off the
script is pretty okay well I was staying
true to source material in the female
perspective is sorely lacking Beck was
real she hunts the pillow multiple times
it's a hero's recognition by the show's
own writers that like the original book
almost everything in you is told from
Joe's point of view with one small
exception in the fourth episode of
season one where some of the episode was
told from Beck's perspective was that
eight seconds there's also a joke about
the somewhat ridiculous alias Candice
uses to hide her identity when she
arrives in LA
you also said your name was Amy Adam
which come to think of it sounds really
stupid what was Britney spirit eat akin
the name Amy Adam is also an Easter Egg
to the book hidden bodies which season
two is based on in the novel Amy is a
completely separate character from
Candice basically she's an ex-girlfriend
of Joe's who runs away from New York
after she scams him Joe then leaves New
York to hunt Amy down with the intention
of killing her the TV show neatly
reverses this by having Amy aka Candice
track Joe down instead the show also
gets to play around with our
expectations of what will happen by the
end of season 2 by getting 40 to deliver
a little red herring early on in the
season when he sits down with Joe to
discuss his script bang marry kill in
the end our guy has to murder all three
women it's like the ultimate irony now
when you watch this for the first time
you might think it means that Joe will
end up killing the three main women in
his life right now
Candice Delilah and love especially when
you think back to how he basically did
the same to three women in season one
Bek peach and Candice who Joe assumed
he'd killed however it's a bit of a red
herring as a surprise villain of the
second season is love who ends up
killing Candice and Delilah and if we
add that she also killed her family's
Opare Sofia that makes love the one to
kill three women by the end season two's
writers also have
some fun with the famous dramatic
principle of Chekhov's gun which for
anyone is unfamiliar is the basic idea
that every element in a story should
serve a purpose and that for example if
you draw attention to a gun then that
gun must go off at some point in the
story in you it's used as a big clue to
who the secret killer of season 2 will
actually be when 40 begins to drunkenly
explain his feature film idea at
Henderson's party its Chekhov's knife
and as soon as we see it nino throats
are gonna get cut but we don't know
who's and don't know why she's cutting
an apple right now but the audience is
gonna be subconsciously terrified this
is a major hint that when we see love
expertly use a knife to butcher a piece
of meat that she'll end up butchering
several people by the end of the season
and Roger knives like this up here
mm-hmm by the way we owe the principle
of Chekhov's gun to influential Russian
playwright and short story writer Anton
Chekhov who hated any elements in a
story making false promises to the
audience and the writers of you joke
around with this idea when 40 tells Joe
about how his scripts developing I don't
think false promises is going to happen
it's a short story not a feature film
check-offs gun also pops up when Joe
breaks into Henderson's basement looking
for evidence of his crimes against
underage girls there he discovers a
robot vacuum cleaner that starts up
automatically in a case of Chekhov's
Roomba the device comes into play on
Joe's next visit after he kills
Henderson when it switches on
automatically a mixes Henderson's blood
with Joe's blood from his nosebleed the
psychological thriller gone girl gets
some interesting references in this
season of you first of all there's a
very deliberate decision to name
Delilah's police officer her cut David
Fincher that's the same name as a
director of gone girl a little detail
that doesn't escape Joe's observation my
officer other day the defender and the
ending of the second season also has
numerous parallels with the ending of
gone girl spoilers for that movie ahead
but you can skip to this timestamp in
case you haven't seen it in the final
episode Murph tells Joe she's pregnant
which is the only thing that stops him
from killing her and leaving similar to
how Rosamund Pike reveals she's pregnant
to Ben Affleck with his child at the end
of gan girl
again is the only reason he decides to
stay with her and the twist in both gone
girl and new season two is that the main
female protagonist is revealed to be a
psychopath or sociopath who secretly
engineered numerous key events in the
story
officer Fincher is also used for
humorous reference for famous TV
detective when Jo snarkily comments that
Fincher operated on nuance of Columbo
and true to Joe's observation in the
final episode before Fincher lets Allie
leave police custody he uses Colombo's
trademark catchphrase oh and one more
thing oh one more thing yes the final
scene of season two is clearly setting
up the third season but there's a very
subtle musical and audio easter egg in
this scene that signals Joe is about to
have his attention drawn to yet another
woman you need to listen very carefully
because as Joe walks out into the garden
and thinks about his fate there's a
little bell sound of the music that
reminds me of the doorbell at Moonies
that rang when beck first entered his
life in the pilot episode but that's not
how destiny works is it
[Music]
well hello over there that doorbell also
rang when Candice came back into Joe's
life at the end of season one and a
little bell is now ringing for Joe at
the end of season two as a brand new
woman seemed set to become the object of
his obsession one of the earliest clues
the writers laid for us about the ending
of season 2 was right in the opening
scene of the first episode when we see
the body of a redheaded actress on a
film set lying in a pool of blood
complete with Candace's signature
leather jacket and heart-shaped
sunglasses and I go into that and all
the other secret clues about love's dark
nature in my ending and twist explained
video tap the screen here or there's a
link you can follow in the video
description so did you spot any other
cool details or Easter eggs in season 2
and what were your favorite moments or
new characters leave your thoughts in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
then I like Anna sure hugely appreciated
tapleft my next new video or tap write
for another video you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers